justice sheffield mike is up on the
mountain tonight making his first start
of the year
24 year old 10 starts for him last year
four and three record
three five eight era for sheffield one
out two on for juan montana
the one two on the edge strike three
quality and it will be the breaking ball
at the bottom of the zone
here's your mean mercedes backhand
crawford
a sling to second sheffield gets out of
the jam carlos rodon
will make his season debut he will
face a mariners lineup that through
three games
it's not a lot they do not have a hit
yet against the left-handed pitcher in
the long run magewell reaches out off
his glove
hanukkah heading for second and madrigal
gets it drops it picks it back
up hannigan hustles into second base
with a double
one and two for ty france 96 threw it
right by him
strike three one gone for carlos rodon
to high school in north carolina holly
springs
swing in a tap right in front of the
plate picked up by grand doll
he will throw to first to get seeger
a big swing there so two on and two outs
runners at first and second no score
bottom of the first inning
that strike three is slider on the
inside corner
and carlos rodon strikes out three well
the mound got better for him
as the inning went along this money
granddaughter chatting
here in the second oh two that's drilled
yes knows it oh goodness gracious bring
him home
that one and no doubter and that was a
slider that didn't get inside far enough
150 of them for a grand doll and he puts
the socks on top
one to nothing that was a blast
not too many guys have tried to do both
here's the pitch on the way check swing
but he goes after a slider down and in
for strike three another strikeout
for sheffield on the slider and that was
a nasty pitch again to a right-handed
hitter
jake fraley in his 73rd career major
league at bat
yep buried in the dirt strike three
fraley is gonna play the worst game of
tag in american history he's out
you might as well just bury that slider
when carlos is right
this is what that slider looked like
justice was one of the
better ground ball starting pitchers in
the game last season
boy tying him up like a pretzel
sheffield spinning to brayu around like
a top there is out number two
he goes back to his best pitch this is
the slider 82 miles an hour down out of
the strike zone
so he's made the adjustment with the
slider so when he gets ahead of the o2
one two two two he will bury it
and mercedes on deck if moncada can keep
this
ending alive for the white sox they've
had traffic every inning
he got him to swing and miss for strike
three
that slider gets monkata for the second
time
a very nice start for carlos radon
against the team that he's handled in
the past
oh it was off and he struck him out
anyway he spun him that slider and
strikeout number five for carlos
jp crawford at 30.
he struck him out and carlos is thrilled
that's a big pitch for him sox trying to
keep their spring alive
and go 16-0 in their last 16 tries
against the left-handed starter
the pitch mercedes cranks one into left
that's a base hit
leadoff single for mercedes great chance
here
fawn faces loaded nobody out
and he got hit a plunking for his first
major league
rbi and the sox are up two two-nothing
billy hamilton despite grounding out his
first time up hit the ball very hard
billy into center field that's a base
hit
a slice job by billy hamilton and the
sox add on to the lead with the rbi
single as he has scores garcia to third
bond to second
this is a big base hit going to the top
of the order
one of the ways you're able to hit like
that is you're anticipating the ball
inside
that's what sheffield does he hasn't
deviated with that fastball and two out
nobody on
is going to turn into a pretty big
inning
madrigal to second moore and crawford
and
white a double play the sox will take
one more garcia scores
he lost three hitters to a base on balls
hagerty breaks his back monkatta comes
home and gets it out there
and that will be it for that play it
goes five to
two bases still loaded two out wouldn't
be surprised if carlos
did get out of this there it is he had
to chase for it and that strike three
that will do it
beautifully done by carlos rodon how
about the player of the week
about it they told you when the season
started that
mercedes would be the player of the week
the first week of the season yep could
get pretty good numbers on that
oh you're mean drills this ball to left
field
and it's off the base of the wall your
mean mercedes one more time
has extra bases and the white sox now
have runners on at second and third with
one out
that kid is on fire folks
that ball's crushed into center yasmani
grandal's had quite the night
that'll bring one more home and the sox
add-on with the rbi single from yaz
here in the fifth a pretty good job by
carlos and
if you're looking for successful outings
regardless of what happens in this one
it's
a successful outing for him strikeout
number
nine pitch
seeger in the air the other way it's
deep at the wall
vaughn makes the catch leaning up
against the wall
in left probably the most challenging
fly
ball so far for andrew vaughn and he
made the play oh i guarantee his heart
was just going pity pat pitty pat
very quickly as he was backpedaling
toward the fence not really knowing
where he was reaching up
and leaning back toward the wall and
crashing into it with his upper back and
looking shocked like did i catch it
now you can sense that most starting
pitchers have got to a point where
they're going hey i just got to get
through five
the 3-2 is muscled out toward left
center
vaughn on the move makes a catch a
couple of nice grabs by
andrew vaughn michael kopeck his only
timeout this year
was wonderfully impressive two innings
one walk and three strikeouts and
96 in the attic strike three michael
kopeck
into the ball game
oh man i mean what are you gonna do no
there's three straight sliders
see ya you got zero chance and each
slider was a bit better than the last
one
it's going to be a great bullpen there
are live arms
no doubt about it nice timing michael
and after the frustration that was
anaheim i mean it was
it was pretty tough there three or four
losses
and this looks to be about it shutout
complete sox win six nothing carlos
rodon michael kopeck
jose ruiz your final thoughts
just a night where everything worked
it's got some clutch pitching when you
needed it
got enough offense and some outstanding
work
by carlos rodon if you're looking for
the starting rotation and a happy ending
to the number five starter
that was it today